une diminution des effectifs de 20% et
des coûts de fonctionnement réduits de
12 % en euros courants
c'est le bilan entre 2015 et 2020 du
gouverneur actuel de la banque de france
un bilan exposé par le principal
intéressé
françois villeroy de galhau dans un
entretien au figaro en mars dernier
cette année la banque de france 2 va
poursuivre sa restructuration avec un
plan social
13 caisses régionales vont donc ainsi
mettre la clé sous la porte
avec la suppression de 131 emplois dans
la filière fiduciaire c'est à dire les
postes en lien avec le stockage et le
tri des billets un plan de départs qui
selon l'institution se ferait sur la
base du volontariat
seulement voilà la motivation économique
de ce projet ne répond pas aux exigences
légales c'est ce qu'ont conclu dans un
rapport des experts des cabinets jd scc
dette que le site spécialisé l'agefi a
pu consulter
la banque de france ne renonce pas pour
autant à procéder à des licenciements
le terme de volontariat est inapproprié
d'autant plus que des licenciements ne
peuvent être exclues une fois la
réorganisation mise en oeuvre les
licenciements obligerait la banque de
france a justifié ce plan par des motifs
économiques
mais certains experts considèrent que
les conditions pour légitimer un
licenciement économique ne sont pas
réunies en effet pour appuyer son projet
l'établissement met en avant je cite
l'accélération du rythme de recul de
l'usagé des espèces et de ses incidences
sur la faible utilisation des outils de
production
or selon le rapport ceci ne constitue
pas un motif économique de licenciement
au regard de la loi
pour la fédération des finances de la
cgt il s'agirait purement et simplement
d'un plan de licenciements déguisés les
postes des agents ben que la direction
souhaite supprimer vont réellement
disparaître avec la structure qui va
fermer
13 caisses sur tout le territoire qui en
compte 37 pour nous c'est tout à fait
abusif de parler de plan de départs
volontaires
ensuite seulement quatre dispositifs
sont proposées aux salariés un
dispositif de reclassement externe à
savoir chercher un emploi ailleurs en
quittant la banque de france
un dispositif de reclassement interne à
savoir candidate et sur un poste
de même catégorie de même type avec le
même métier au sein de réseaux de
succursales de la banque de france
sachant que ce réseau est déjà très
affaibli et va subir d'autres
suppressions de postes dans les mois qui
viennent en tout cas c'est ce que ce que
dit la direction
un dispositif de promotion interne qui
est complètement à la main de
l'employeur avec aucune garantie est le
seul dispositif qui peut être
intéressant pour les argents mais qui du
coup ne peut être actionnée que par un
petit nombre d'entre eux la banque de
france souhaite aussi se désengager d'un
autre pan de son activité à savoir la
gestion de la monnaie fiduciaire usagers
une aberration pour la cgt c'est
l'argent du secteur privé tri déjà une
partie des billets qui auparavant
étaient triés spécifiquement par les
agents de gare banque de france
aujourd'hui il ya 34 % des coupures en
circulation qui sont triés par les
transporteurs de fonds privés ce que
nous dit notre direction c'est qu'elle
elle va autoriser ces acteurs privés à
trier 60% du volume de billets en
circulation selon le syndicat la banque
de france pourrait subventionner à
hauteur de 3 millions d'euros par an les
acteurs privés qui prendrait en charge
cette partie de son activité
d'autres agences régionales pourraient
encore être amenés à fermer à partir de
la fin 2022